if someone said hey hundred can i take
you out for coffee or or dinner
and i'm about to leave my day job i can
you just can you talk me through it
because i'm really scared i have this
good
gig but i'm not fulfilled and i've
gotten insurance and
and i really i've got some money set
aside
they take you to a nice place you sit
down what would you tell them
i would say leave your day job if you're
thinking about it
because there's more day jobs to come
and unless we all crash which
we'll all do it together there's going
to continue to be jobs as far as i'm
concerned if yourself
a self-think you're a motivator you know
somebody who's motivated and can make
stuff happen
then take your chance to leave your day
job i think we'll all
ultimately maybe know when to go back i
hope
i i say that too and i caution i throw a
little caution out there because i have
had that moment
back in 2008 when everything was
crashing and i was kind of in that
i don't know films for me and i started
looking a little bit at jobs and and
it's it was tough you know it was
definitely that tough feeling of like i
don't know if i can get a job anymore
like it's it's i don't know if i can be
that sort of like here's my resume
and here's all the things i've done sort
of person you know um
and so uh i do i'll say just be careful
what i say
if you do sit down with me but uh
seriously go for it i mean you take
take these chances this is our time in
life to get to take chances and do cool
things and you watch 10 miles per hour
and that's my principle and
you know i've met a lot of people along
the way that have seen that film and
it's helped
ultimately i think affect their decision
to to quit
go for something else so what type of
checklist
should someone make what it's like to
almost they're packing for a camping
trip
if they're going to leave a day job
let's suppose they realize okay there
are
many other jobs to come in my lifetime
but i may not have the time and energy
that i do now
at this age so i'm going to do it what
would you tell them what are some of the
actual like
you know whether have this much amount
of rent or mortgage in the bank or you
know i mean like real
concrete steps yeah i think if you want
to
leave your job uh to try something new i
think you definitely should try to have
some savings
set set aside and you know that would
depend on if you've got a mortgage or
or those types of things i'd be afraid
not to i mean i would
i would say that you should kind of
evaluate what you really need what you
have to have
and and be okay with potentially
separating yourself
from some of the things that you're
you're you know sort of hooked on
um i've often found when you make those
changes in life it brings
you know so much so much reward to you
um
and then have a plan you know give
yourself a time time frame for
do developing what you want to do if
it's a film
great i mean don't think that you can go
out and make a film in a few months it's
going to take
typically a year to two years at least
for your first film to really develop it
shoot it
and and get it finished for some people
it takes a lot longer
i think it's very important to put
pressure on yourself and those that
you're working with like i try not to
put
i try not to allow more than two years
to span for the whole lapse of
development
and you know production and post
production and ultimately distribution
you know i mean distribution kind of
goes on but the main core
initial phase of distribution is you
know usually a few to several months
so my goal you know ultimately with
films is
you know definitely give yourself a
limit and that's with any
of any project and if you get out there
and you quit your job and you've done
this and
it's not working for you don't be afraid
to go back and and work again
at a day job for a little while and
rethink you know reinvent i think that
too many times we get too scared about
oh no what's going to happen and really
well i'll be fine
you know you might be in a little bit of
financial duress for a while but
who cares you can you can use your
experiences that you found by
by quitting your job and trying
something different to ultimately find a
better job that pays better and you can
pay things off quickly i mean
i was i was in debt about 40 000
after my first film and and 10 miles per
hour and i remember when we were
releasing it you know we're making back
a little bit of that money but then we
were trying to make another film
and we were trying to we were trying to
get out of this hole and i was
definitely stuck in a hole of lots of
debt and for me that felt like a lot of
debt at that time
it was on credit cards and i can
remember when you know we were able to
use
use this like kind of scheme to prevent
the interest from hitting and then the
interest started hitting both josh and i
were like
man what are we going to do you know and
that's that was the time when i was like
okay time to get a job for a while and i
went back got a job and i just worked
very hard to pay those those credit
cards off that was my top priority i
wanted to
as fast as i could get out of that den
took a couple years
but i was able to do it and and that
gave me
a lot of life again but there was a
period of time was dark
it was hard it was like i can't make
these films this is a this is a joke
well
fortunately some like 10 miles per hour
you know had a few deals and
and some some money did come in and we
were able to use the money that was
coming in
to help you know to help get rid of that
debt a little quicker
that's not the case for everybody i know
sometimes your films just don't
don't seem to to hit or take off
you